The core Hadoop project consists of a way to store
data, known as the Hadoop distributed file system, or HDFS. And
a way to process data with MapReduce. The key concept is
that we split the data up and store it across the
collection of machines known as a cluster. Then when we want
to process the data, we process it where it's actually stored.
Rather than retrieving the data from a central server, the data's
already on the cluster, so we can process it in place.
You can add more machines to the cluster
as the amount of data you're storing grows.
And, indeed, many people start with just a
few machines, and add more as they're needed.
The machines in your cluster don't need to
be anything particularly high end. Although most clusters
are built using rack-mounted servers, they are typically
mid-range servers, rather than top of the range equipment.